you can't put this off forever into the
heart of darkness as a simulation of a
trip through a house of horrors until
dawn rush of blood gets the basics right
there's blood
murderous personas and abandoned
decrepit structures around every corner
rather than meander on foot you sit in a
cart on Rails that automatically moves
forward through these demented
environments at first you're gonna
proper set of horrific but safe
environments armed with an air pistol
but it doesn't take long for the game to
give way to more realistic threats and
issue shotguns and revolvers in favour
of play guns though it transforms and
tries to evoke true horror rush of blood
remains a benign experience that fails
to elicit real fear it's ultimately a
basic light gun like game with jump
scares but you can see them coming from
a mile away with the PlayStation Move
controller in each hand and a
PlayStation VR headset on your noggin
your primary task is to keep an eye out
for bad guys that either run directly at
you or throw objects from the safety of
cover aim fire and reload as quickly as
you can
or you might end up dying from a few
unfortunate hits should you die you
respawn in close proximity the one
exception is the insane difficulty
setting which forces you to restart a
level when you die these levels include
gruesome warehouses filled with
squealing and dismembered pig carcasses
a haunted mental hospital with ghastly
figures that dart in and out of sight
and a rundown carnival with sections of
spooky woodlands there are seven levels
in total but they tend to bleed together
in hindsight rush of blood is fairly
consistent in the tone and atmosphere of
its settings save for the surprising and
vastly different final level they're all
dreadful and occasionally gross and last
about 10 to 15 minutes apiece as you
Trumble through shadows and murky
frights you're accosted by the usual
cast of horror bad guys thugs and clown
masks animated mannequins zombie like
fiends and spiders arachnophobia where
with decent motion tracking in effect
aiming your shots with PlayStation Move
controllers comes naturally after a few
minutes and you quickly learn how to
react to threats in front of you and in
your peripheral vision there are some
scenes where you have to frantically
react to succeed but a keen eye in a
calm disposition is all that's required
once you understand the relationship
between the controllers in your virtual
guns there are small selection of
powerful weapons hidden in colorful
boxes but they only prove necessary
during the game's final encounter
otherwise serving as a way to add some
much-needed variety most threats follow
routines and are generally easy to kill
enemies from afar pop in and out of
cover and incoming enemies simply sidle
up to your cart if you don't shoot them
right away making for truly easy targets
there's one gasoline mini boss that
Sprint's to and fro making it difficult
to hit from a distance but again all you
have to do is wait for it to get in your
face fire a couple of rounds into it and
repeat the process until it's dead rush
of blood other threats come in the form
of obstacles that intrude upon your
personal space to avoid them you simply
need to lean to one side or duck grant
it there are some moments where the cart
is moving quickly and you have to react
accordingly but you typically have
plenty of warning as the cart moves slow
and steady obstacles and rush of blood
feel like nothing more than filler they
aren't scary and they don't pose a
meaningful threat
all told rush of blood can be completed
roughly in an hour and a half and when
it's all said and done it doesn't seem
like an experience that would greatly
benefit from repeated playthroughs there
are a few alternate paths you can unlock
in a couple of levels but they generally
lead to more of the same just in a
different arrangement
it's got disturbing taste overall but
that alone can't save what amounts to a
largely predictable experience filled
with straightforward action dumb enemies
and cliched friends
you